This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantu. In 2011, Richard Freeman was working on a project. He was studying the way groups of people work together, specifically how scientists work together. Richard, who's a Harvard economics professor, noticed something intriguing. Scientists in the United States seem to stick to their own kind. You'd see Chinese folk concentrated in one lab,
这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。2011年，理查德·弗里曼正在从事一个项目。他当时在研究人们如何协同工作，特别是科学家们如何合作。身为哈佛大学经济学教授的理查德注意到一个有趣的现象。美国的科学家似乎倾向于和同类人抱团。你会发现，华裔科学家往往集中在一个实验室里，
Indian folk concentrated in another lab, Europeans of different groups, associating more with their compatriots. This was not surprising. You see this kind of clustering in lots of workplaces. But Richard thought, science ought to be different. In general, people who are more alike, are likely to think more alike, and one of the things that gives a kick to science and scientific productivity
印度裔科学家集中在另一个实验室，而来自不同群体的欧洲人也更多地与同胞交往。这并不让人意外。你在许多工作场所都能看到这种抱团现象。但理查德认为，科学理应有所不同。总的来说，相似度更高的人往往思考方式也更相似，而激发科学活力与科研产出的因素之一，
is that you get people with somewhat different views, different perspectives coming together. This assertion has long been debated. Some people say teams with lots of different perspectives come up with better ideas. Others say, no, when a group has lots of different views, this can produce conflict, gridlock. So, which is it? Richard decided to put the question to the test. Do scientists who collaborate with others from the same group produce better science or worse science than scientists who have a wide network of collaborators? To find out, Richard looked at one of the most important signals of scientific success,
正是让那些有着不同观点、不同视角的人汇聚一堂。这种主张长期以来一直备受争论。有人说，拥有多元视角的团队能迸发出更好的创意。另一些人则认为，不对，当一个群体存在大量不同意见时，反而会产生冲突和僵局。那么，究竟是哪一种呢？理查德决定通过实验来验证这个问题。与同一群体的人合作的科学家，其产出的科研成果是更好还是更糟？相比之下，那些拥有广泛合作网络的人呢？为了找出答案，理查德考察了衡量科学成功最重要的指标之一：
research publications. He surveyed vast numbers of articles and papers, and he found that in a large number of these papers, co-authors shared a common ethnicity. No surprise. But then he went further. There's a very powerful way to judge the quality of scientific papers. The more groundbreaking a paper, the more likely it is to be cited by researchers writing other papers. Citations, in other words, are a marker of importance.
研究论文。他调查了大量的文章和论文，发现其中很大一部分论文的共同作者都具有相同的种族背景。这并不奇怪。但他决定进一步深入探究。评估科学论文质量有一个非常有力的方法。一篇论文越具突破性，被其他撰写论文的研究人员引用的可能性就越大。换句话说，引用次数是衡量重要性的一个标志。
We ask, well, are the papers done by people who are more ethnically the same? Are those papers, do they get more attention? Do they have more citations? Do they appear in journals that are greater prestige? The answer was no. If you write a paper all largely with people of your own group, it's likely the paper gets less citations than if you write it with a broader group of people. People is that got the most citations, the most prestige,
我们不禁要问，那些由种族背景更单一的人撰写的论文，会获得更多关注吗？它们的引用次数更多吗？它们会发表在声望更高的期刊上吗？答案是否定的。如果你写一篇论文，合作者大多来自你自己的群体，那么这篇文章获得的引用次数，很可能比你和一个更广泛的群体合作撰写的论文要少。那些获得最多引用、享有最高声誉的论文，
were often written by a mix of people with different backgrounds. It is much better to have people working in collaborating when they're across different laboratories, across different parts of the US, between countries rather than people only working in the same group. Defining hell true, no matter which ethnic groups you look at. This is a result that goes across all the groups.
通常是由具有不同背景的人共同撰写的。人们跨实验室、跨美国不同地区、甚至跨国进行合作，其效果远胜于仅仅在同一群体内部共事。事实证明，无论你关注的是哪种族群，这条规律都颠扑不破。这是一个适用于所有群体的结果。
So it's not specific like Chinese guys write a paper together, their paper gets less citations, less impact. The same thing is true if they've born Anglo-American through that. In other words, that you're actually at a disadvantage if you are surrounded by people of your own group, in some ways, regardless of what that group is. Yes, and I think the key thing is to get more ideas
所以这并非某种特定现象，比如不是说华裔学者合写了一篇论文，他们的论文引用率就低、影响力就小。Anglo-American（盎格鲁-美利坚人）群体也是如此。换句话说，在某种程度上，无论你属于哪个群体，如果周围全是同类人，你其实是处于劣势的。是的，我认为关键在于将更多的创意
sort of linked together so they can spawn better ideas, as opposed to us all working in the same way. We're going to explore a single idea today that builds upon Richard's finding in science. We look at this idea's applications in the arts, in fashion, and in business. It's about the strange connection between the kind of ideas we dream up and the kind of people who surround us. Diversity and creativity. This week on Hidden Brain. In the far northwest of Spain, it's a place of farms and forests and ocean.
进行某种连结，从而催生出更好的想法，而不是所有人都在用同一种方式工作。今天，我们将探讨一个基于理查德在科学界发现的单一理念。我们将探讨这一理念在艺术、时尚和商业领域的应用。这关乎我们构思的创意与我们周围人群之间奇妙的联系。多元化与创造力。本周的《隐藏大脑》。在西班牙的极西北部，那是一个充满农田、森林和海洋的地方。
Galicia. It's a region of rugged coastlines, hardy's twos, and the Galithian Backpipe. I come from Odense, which is one of the four provinces of Galithia. This is Christina Pato, she's a Backpipe player. When you grew up in Galithia, you grew up hearing music everywhere, hearing music in a bar, hearing music in a square, celebrating the festivities of the day or in weddings or in even birthdays. I mean, when you are in Galicia, you pretty much can hear the backpipes almost everywhere. can hear the backpipes almost everywhere. Christina's been playing the backpipes since she was a child. She grew up in a musical household.
加利西亚。这是一个拥有崎岖海岸线、坚韧居民和加利西亚风笛的地区。我来自奥伦塞，它是加利西亚的四个省份之一。这是克里斯蒂娜·帕托，她是一名风笛手。在加利西亚长大，你从小就会听到音乐无处不在，在酒吧里、在广场上听到音乐，在庆祝节日时、在婚礼上甚至在生日时听到音乐。我的意思是，当你在加利西亚时，你几乎到处都能听到风笛声。几乎到处都能听到风笛声。克里斯蒂娜从小就在吹风笛。她在音乐世家中长大。
Her father was an accordion player. Her three older sisters all played the backpipes. And I just wanted to be whatever my sisters were doing. So they began with the backpipes when I was four years old. So I just did it. The girls were talented. By the time she was 10, Christina and her sister Raquel were traveled to villages to play at festivals.
她的父亲是一位手风琴手。她的三个姐姐都会吹风笛。而我只是想做姐姐们在做的事情。所以当我四岁时，她们开始学风笛，我也跟着学了。姐妹们都很有天赋。到了十岁时，克里斯蒂娜和姐姐拉克尔开始前往各个村庄在节日上演出。
My mother will give us the collision dresses, and then we will start walking in those streets. And the sound of two backpipes at 8 a.m. is something that everybody can not only hear, but also recognize. My sister and I will be just waiting for them to come out, play a little Muneera, which is the Galicia National Dance. And people will just start dancing around. As she grew older, Christina began to experiment with her backpipes. She started to play music that wasn't embedded in the folkloric tradition.
我母亲会给我们穿上加利西亚的传统连衣裙，然后我们就开始走上那些街道。清晨八点，两把风笛的声音不仅震耳欲聋，而且极具辨识度。我和姐姐会等着它们响起，演奏一曲《穆涅拉》（Muneera），这是加利西亚的国舞。人们便会开始围着翩翩起舞。随着年龄的增长，克里斯蒂娜开始尝试用风笛进行创新。她开始与乐队一起巡演。18岁时，她发行了第一张个人专辑。克里斯蒂娜的音乐尝试越多，她的技艺就越精湛。两年后，当她的第二张专辑发行时，她把头发染成了亮绿色，并获得了一个外号——“风笛界的吉米·亨德里克斯”。对于一些传统主义者来说，克里斯蒂娜已经越界了。在加利西亚，风笛依然深深植根于传统之中。但即兴演奏对她来说是自然而然的。她需要创造出属于她自己的音乐。
She started touring with bands. At 18, she released her first solo album. The more Christina stretched, the better she got. By the time her second album was released two years later, she died her hair bright green and acquired a nickname The Jimmy Hendrix of the Backpipes For some traditionalists, Christina was stepping over a line. In Galicia, the backpipes remained deeply embedded in tradition. But improvisation came naturally to her. She needed to make her own kind of music.
我当时只是想告诉人们，这就是我。并不是说我不在乎你对我和我的乐器有什么看法，而是我对乐器所做的一些事情，在推动着我不断前进。到了青年时期，克里斯蒂娜不得不做出选择。在她看来，风笛似乎只能带她走到这里了。克里斯蒂娜还接受过古典钢琴的训练。二十多岁时，她决定离开西班牙前往美国。她打算追求主流的音乐事业，
I was trying to just tell people this is what I am and I is not like I don't care about what you think about what I do with my instrument, but there is something about what I do with my instrument that keeps me going. By the time she was a young adult, Christina had to make a choice. It seemed to her like the backpipes could only take her so far. Christina had also been trained in classical piano. In her mid-20s, she decided to leave Spain and go to the United States. She would pursue a mainstream musical career
而使用的乐器是钢琴。于是我搬到了这里。当我前往罗格斯大学攻读博士学位时，我没有告诉身边的任何人，我开启了另一段人生。克里斯蒂娜将她的两重生活分得清清楚楚。她的一面是一个勤奋的古典音乐学生顶着绿发的加利西亚风笛手。有一天，在她的第二个学期，一位教授请求她帮忙翻译一首歌。
with a piano. And I moved here. I didn't tell anybody around me when I went to Rackers' University to get my doctorate, then I had another life. Christina kept her two lives separate. One side of her was a diligent classical music student. The other was still a green-haired back-py player from Galithia. One day in her second semester, a professor asked for help in translating a song.
所以我接到声乐系教授的电话，她说：“我这里有一首歌，它的语言似乎和西班牙语很接近。”我想知道你能不能担任这位歌手的钢琴伴奏，同时兼任声乐教练来指导发音。当我看到这首歌时，它是《L'Aura di Scomparire》，用加利西亚语字面意思是“无色之月”。这是一首由19世纪末最伟大的加利西亚女性作家罗莎莉亚·德·卡斯特罗创作的诗。而这位作曲家——说实话，我对他一无所知——
So I get this call from the professor of the vocal department and she says, I have a son in here which is in a language that I believe is closer to Spanish. So I was wondering if you could be the pianist for this singer and also the coach, the vocal coach for diction. And when I see this car, it was Lua de Escolorida, which is literally colorless moon in Galithian. And this was a poem by the most amazing Galician poet of all times, Rosalia de Castro, a female griter of the end of the 19th century. And this composer who, to be honest, I didn't know anything about him,
这位作曲家竟然挑选了那首诗并为之谱曲。这位作曲家后来大有来头，是一位名叫奥斯瓦尔多·戈利霍夫的阿根廷人。她在一次排练中遇到了他。我们开始聊起加利西亚。然后他变得很兴奋。接着我告诉他：“其实我还演奏加利西亚的另一个、也是最重要的东西，
this composer actually has chosen that poem to create music around it. That composer, it turns out, was celebrated, an Argentinian named Oswald O'Golihoff. She met him at rehearsal. We started talking about Galicia. Then he got excited. Then I told him, well, I actually played the other, the other most important thing about Galicia,
那就是加利西亚的风笛。”然后他的眼睛睁得更大 L。快进到六个月后，克里斯蒂娜接到了一个电话。是奥斯瓦尔多打来的。他说：“你和你丈夫为什么不来伦诺克斯呢？我这几年经常和一些朋友聚会，带上你的风笛，来和我们一起玩得开心点。”于是他们去了。
which is Negalicia's backpipe. And then his eyes opened even wider. Fast forward six months, Christina got a call. It was Oswaldo. He says, why don't you and your husband come to Lenox, as I choose it some year with some friends being your backpack and yeah, just come and have fun with us. So they did?
我们实际上抵达了唐格wood，那是他们聚会的地方。我们见到了奥斯瓦尔多，开始交谈，他说：“今晚我们在伦诺克斯住的地方有一个聚会，我希望你能向大家展示你的乐器，简单谈谈你们的传统、你的音乐以及你所做的事情，我相信他们一定会喜欢的。”于是我就在那儿，和一群陌生人一起演奏我的乐器，而在场我唯一能认出的人是约约。约约？约约。约约？
We arrived in Tanglewood actually, that's where they were meeting. We see Osvaldo, we started talking and he says, well tonight we are having like gathering in the place where we are staying in Lennogs and I was hoping for you just to show them your instrument, talk a little bit about your tradition, your music, what you do and I'm sure they will love it. So there I was, like playing my instrument with a bunch of strangers that I, the only person I could recognize physically, it was Jojo. Jojo? Jojo. Jojo?
约约，大提琴家马友友。世界上最知名、最著名的大提琴家。克里斯蒂娜当时没有意识到，她误打误撞走进了一个挤满来自世界各地音乐大师的房间。他们是马友友创立的一个团体成员。这是一个名为“丝绸之路合奏团”的集体，它汇聚了来自不同文化和不同传统的音乐家。
Jojo, Jojo, Ma, the cellist. The most renowned and famous cellist in the world. What Christina didn't realize was that she'd stumbled into a room filled with master musicians from around the world. They were part of a group created by Jojo Ma. It's a collective known as the Silk Road ensemble, and it brings together musicians from different cultures and different traditions.
我很幸运，那天我甚至不知道我是在为谁演奏，因为如果我知道的话，我可能就不会那么自由地去思考这些人是谁、我在他们所有人面前到底在做什么了。我开始演奏，他们开始提问，我兴奋起来，然后我邀请他们加入进来一起演奏，结果那天晚上，我们最后都在跳加利西亚的《穆涅拉》，而我还教了他们怎么跳。那个时刻真的改变了我的
I kind of was lucky that that night I didn't even know who I was playing for because if I did, probably would not have felt so free in the idea of where are these people, what am I doing in front of all of them? I began playing, they started asking questions, I got excited, then I asked them to join and play and then we ended up that evening, all dancing a Galihian Muneera that I coached them how to dance. And that moment really changed my
人生，走向了每一个可能的方向。而在那个时刻，我甚至没有意识到这个时刻对于我的余生将意味着什么。这是一个转折点。克里斯蒂娜加入了丝绸之路合奏团。她拥抱了该集体的愿景，这个愿景始于一个简单的问题。当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？当陌生人相遇时会发生什么？这就是马友友提出的问题。来自许多不同文化的音乐家
life in every possible direction. And in that moment, I didn't even realize how much the moment was going to mean for the rest of my life. It was a turning point. Christina joined the Silk Road ensemble. She embraced the vision for the collective, a vision that began with a simple question. What could happen when a stranger's meet? What could happen when strangers meet? This is the question Yoyo Mahadast. What could musicians from many different
当他们聚在一起时，能创造出什么？事实证明，是一些异常美妙的东西。马友友将该集体的作品描述为他所谓的“边缘效应”。克里斯蒂娜说，这是一个深深印在她脑海中的概念。边缘效应是指两个生态系统交汇的点，比如森林和稀树草原，而在生态学中，正是在这种边缘效应中产生了最多的新生命形式，不知何故，丝绸之路某种程度上就是对这种边缘效应的重现。对克里斯蒂娜来说，在那个新生命形式涌现的地带工作，改变了她看待音乐的方式。
cultures create when they come together? It turns out something extraordinarily beautiful. Jojo Ma describes the work of the collective as something he calls the edge effect. Christina says it's an idea that stuck with her. The edge effect is the pointing which two ecosystems meet like the forest and the savannah and apparently in ecology in this edge effect is where the most new life forms are created and somehow Silk Road is some sort of his recreation of this edge effect. For Christina, working in that zone where new life forms emerge, that changed the way she saw music.
她开始质疑，为什么风笛手克里斯蒂娜和古典钢琴家克里斯蒂娜必须生活在不同的世界里。确实，音乐不同，传统不同，甚至连观众看起来也不同。但那又怎样？突然间，通过与丝绸之路的合作，我找到了我一生中生活的两个世界之间的联系，而在我的家乡，这两个世界甚至毫无交集。你必须明白，在我出身的奥伦塞，
She began to question why Christina, the backpipe player, and Christina, the classical pianist, had to live in different worlds. It's true, the music was different, the traditions were different, even the audiences seemed different. But so what? All of a sudden, working with Silrod, I found the connections between the two worlds I've been living on my life that were not even connected in my hometown. And you have to understand also that in Orénse where I
风笛学校和古典音乐音乐学院是两栋紧挨着的建筑。在一个拥有十万人口的城市里，这所风笛学校有超过一万人以某种方式与它产生过关联。而我屈指可数，能同时去两边的人少之又少——既去接受古典音乐培训，也去学习风笛。克里斯蒂娜说，吸引她的是不同音乐形式之间建立联系和对话的可能性。
come from, the Backpipers School and the Conservatory for Classical Music were two buildings next to each other. This Backpipers School had in a city of a hundred thousand people, had more than ten thousand somehow involved with the Backpipers School. And I could count with the fingers of my hands, the people that could actually go to both, to go training classical music, but also go train the Zeppelin Piper. Christina says that what drew her was the possibility for connections and conversations between different musical forms.
在丝绸之路，你还必须不断前进，结识新的陌生人，融入新的社群，与那些你从未想象过能与之合作的群体打交道。也许还要将那些你认为永远无法融合的乐器组合在一起，比如加利西亚风笛和日本尺八。比如加利西亚风笛和日本尺八。
In Silver Road, you also have to keep going and meeting new strangers, meeting new communities, meeting communities of people that you have never imagined of working with. And maybe putting together instruments that you will never think they will work together like a Galician backed by panace Japanese Sakuhachi. the Yambakpai Pana Japanese Sakuhachi.
对我来说，丝绸之路在某种程度上是21世纪社会的隐喻，或者至少是我对21世纪社会的期许。自由的社会。丝绸之路的音乐家们在音乐中发现了理查德·弗里曼在科学中发现的规律：当来自不同群体的人们聚在一起时，有趣的事情就会发生。共同工作。碰撞。稍后回来，我们将探讨科学，解释为什么多元化与创造力往往密不可分。
Somehow to me, Silk Road is the metaphor of the 21st century society, or at least to the wish I have for the 21st century society. the free society. The Silk Road musicians have discovered in music what Richard Freeman discovered in science. The interesting stuff happens when people from different groups come together. Work together. Collide. When we come back, we'll take a look at the science that explains why diversity and creativity often go hand in hand.
请继续收听。哈喽，哈喽，嗨，亚当，我是香卡。很高兴见到你。不久前，当我在纽约时，我顺道拜访了社会心理学家亚当·吉林斯基的公寓。我和制片人吉尼·施密特到达那里时，亚当和他的家人正等在前门口。亚当与他的妻子珍·奥里昂、两个年幼的儿子阿瑟和艾丹以及他的岳母维基·奥里昂住在一起。当我们走入公寓时，亚当提出了一个小小的请求。
Stay with us. Hello, hello, hi, Adam, I'm Shankar. Nice to meet you. Not long ago when I was in New York, I stopped by the apartment of social psychologist Adam Gylinski. When we produced a genie Schmidt and I got there, Adam and his family were waiting for us at the front door. Adam lives with his wife, Jen O'Lion, his two young sons, Asher and Aiden, and his mother-in-law, Vicki O'Lion. As we walked into the apartment, Adam made a quick request.
你们想把鞋子脱掉吗？我们脱下了靴子，亚当和珍指着长凳下放着的一排室内鞋。如果你喜欢的话，这里有一些防滑拖鞋。哦太好了，好的。或者鞋套是我的最爱。亚当承认，家里不穿鞋并不是他从小到大的习惯。在遇到、也就是和珍约会之前，我从来没在自己家里脱过鞋，而且，
Did you want to take it off your shoes? We slipped off our boots, and Adam and Jen pointed to a selection of house shoes they kept under a bench. Here's some slip-wise if you like. Oh great, okay. Or booties are my favorite. Adam admits that having a shoe-free house wasn't something he'd done growing up. I'd never taken my shoes off in my own house before meeting, you know, dating Jen, and,
你知道的，珍甚至不希望我们穿着外面的衣服坐在床上。所以，我真的把这融入了生活，我现在去酒店也会先脱掉裤子再坐在床上。珍对于将家的内部与外部世界隔离开来有着强烈的理念。随着时间推移，亚当已经把这些理念变成了他自己的。我认为这确实让我以一种完全不同的方式思考空间，以及人们如何
you know, Jen even doesn't want us to put our clothes on, outside clothes on sitting on the bed. So, I really integrated this like, I go to hotels now and I take off my pants before sitting on the bed. Jen has strong ideas about keeping the inside of a home separate from the outside world. Over time, Adam has made those ideas his own. I think that that's really made me think about space in a totally different way and sort of how people
构建他们的世界和室内环境。现在我家的室内设计比我单身时要好得多。亚当在北卡罗来纳州的一个世俗犹太家庭中长大。珍在康涅狄格州长大，她的父母是从菲律宾移民过去的。他们保留了菲律宾文化。这种文化的一部分包括对家庭的深深敬意，
construct their worlds and their interior environments. And I have much better interior design now in my house than I ever had when I was single. Adam grew up in a secular Jewish family in North Carolina. Jen grew up in Connecticut with parents who'd immigrated from the Philippines. They'd held on to their Filipino culture. Part of that culture includes a deep respect for the home
这种敬意被传给了珍。珍反过来又将这种文化信仰传给了亚当。其实我至今仍拥有我在芝加哥的公寓，我最近回去过一次。当时我想，以前这一切简直太逊了。我从来没有关注过空间的所有特征，不像那些真正关心设计以及事物如何搭配的人那样。
or respect they passed on to Jen. Jen in turn passed on that cultural belief to Adam. I still actually own my apartment in Chicago and I went back to it recently. And I'm like, basically, what a f*** all this was. I was just never attentive to all the features of a space that someone who really cares about that and design and how things fit together.
我想现在的卧室感觉更像一个避难所了。这几乎就像是你跨越了，你知道的，进入了另一个传送门，如果你愿意这么说的话。珍也接纳了亚当的一些价值观。亚当通过他的犹太传统教会了我去拥抱、敞开心扉并感受情绪，也就是给情绪贴标签、进行识别。
And I think that the bedroom now is like, it does feel a little bit more like a sanctuary. And it's almost like you're stepping across, you know, this into this different portal if you will. Jen is also adopted. Some of Adam's values. Adam has taught me through his Jewish tradition about embracing opening up a feeling, so labeling, identifying feelings.
我往往会压抑这些东西，或者不喜欢真正的冲突。所以我不会刻意去避开它。现在，你可能会问，这有什么大不了的？任何一对情侣走到一起，都会融合彼此的生活，接受一些东西，放下另一些来自各自背景的东西。但不同之处在于：当来自不同国家或文化的人结合在一起时，这似乎会影响他们的创造力。亚当一直在研究这个课题。
I tend to mute those things or don't like real conflict. So I don't steer out of it. Now, you might be asking, what's the big deal? Any time a couple gets together, they blend their lives, embrace some things, let go of others. But here's the difference. When people from different countries or cultures come together, it seems to affect their creativity. Adam has studied this topic.
当珍和孩子们不在时，我们进行了一场更深入的交谈。我想知道他是如何对多元化与创造力之间的联系产生兴趣的。亚当说这一切要追溯到他还在上高中的很久以前。在出发去海外交换一个学期之前，他参加了一个强制性的新生指导会。亚当说这一切要追溯到他还在上高中的很久以前。在出发去海外交换一个学期之前，他参加了一个强制性的新生指导会。我至今仍记得，当时他们说：
We caught up for a longer chat when Jen and the kids weren't around. I wanted to know how he'd gotten interested in the link between diversity and creativity. Adam says it started long ago when he was in high school. Before leaving for a semester abroad, he'd attended a mandatory orientation. Adam says it started long ago when he was in high school. Before leaving for a semester abroad, he'd attended a mandatory orientation. And I still remember to this day, they said,
“听着，亚当，你要去中国。在中国，盘子里剩下食物是尊重的一种标志，因为这说明你吃饱了。但在你要去的印度尼西亚，盘子里剩下食物却是不尊重的标志，因为这基本上说明这不好吃。”所以对我来说，那是一次开阔眼界、具有变革意义的体验，让我认识到同一个事物——
look, summer, you're going to go to China. And in China, it is a sign of respect if you leave food on your plate, because it says that you got enough to eat. But in Indonesia, where I was going, it's a sign of disrespect to leave food on your plate, because it basically says the food wasn't very good. And so that was sort of eye-opening, transformational experience for me to recognize the same object
盘子里的食物——根据文化的不同，可以有完全不同的含义，并带来完全不同的影响。相同的事情有着不同的含义，这取决于你的背景和视角。这让亚当好奇，不同的 cultures（文化）如何能帮助我们以不同的方式看待世界，并激发创造力和创新。多年后，他决定在一个研究项目中探索这些想法。整个项目是一个极好的故事，因为它既是科学发现又是科学合作的一个优秀范例。
food on a plate could have very different meanings and have very different implications depending on the culture. The same thing means different things, depending on your background and perspective. It made Adam wonder how different cultures can help us see the world differently and spark creativity and innovation. Years later, he decided to explore these ideas in a research project. The whole project is a great story because it's a good example of both scientific discovery and scientific collaboration.
亚当和一些同事追踪了一所商学院的一群学生。研究人员假设，在学业结束时表现出最高创造力的学生，也正是那些与来自不同国家的人有最多互动的人。他们收集了大量的数据并进行了计算分析。正当他们准备发表时……另一组研究人员其实设计出了比我们更好的方案，抢先一步采用了我们的创意并发表了论文。这本该是结束的时候。
Adam and some colleagues track a group of students at a business school. The researchers hypothesized that the students who showed the most creativity at the end of their school years would also be those who had the most interactions with people from different countries. The collective vast amount of data crunched the results. They were about to publish when... Another group of researchers had actually even a better design than we did and scooped our idea and publish the paper. That should have been the end of it.
他们的目标是发表论文，结果却被人抢先了。所以尽管他们掌握了大量数据，却把它们全都收起来，继续前进了。几年后，我有一名一年级博士生杰克逊·刘，我对他说：“嘿，我们有这些旧数据。我们无法在顶级期刊上发表，因为别人已经抢先发表了，但我们可以把它作为一项复现研究来发表。你为什么不把这些数据过一遍呢？”接下来发生的事情，或许就是理查德·弗里曼注意到的那种现象的一个例证——让具有不同种族背景的科学家参与进来，对科研项目大有裨益。杰克逊·刘在亚当的数据中发现了一个令人兴奋的亮点，而亚当本人却忽略了这一点。我问：“那是什么？”他说：“我发现了这样一个
Their goal had been to publish and they'd gotten beat. So even though they had a lot of data, they put it all away and moved on. A couple years later, I had a first-year doctoral student in Jackson, Lew, and I said, hey, we have this old data. We can't publish in a great journal because someone already scooped us on it, but we could publish it as a replication simmer good. Why don't you go through the data? What happened next might be an example of the phenomenon Richard Freeman noticed that it helps a research project to have scientists from different ethnicities. Jackson Lew saw something exciting in Adam's data that Adam himself had overlooked. And I said, what's that? And he said, I found this
结果：和不同文化背景的人约会过的人，在商学院学习期间变得更有创造力了，但那些仅仅和不同文化背景的人交过朋友的人，似乎并没有变得更有创造力。”因此，跨文化恋爱关系有着某种独特而美妙之处。杰克逊的热情让亚当和他的同事们精神为之一振。他们意识到自己可能偶然发现了一些重要的事情。为什么和不同文化背景的人约会能激发创造力？为什么泛泛的友谊不会产生同样的效果呢？于是我们再次开始思考这个概念：深度，即
finding that people who had dated someone from another culture became more creative during their business school career, but those who just had friends from another culture didn't seem to become more creative. So there's something unique and wonderful about intercultural romantic relationships. Jackson's enthusiasm made Adam and his colleague sit up. They realized they may have stumbled on something important. Why would dating someone from another culture, spoke creativity? Why would casual friendships not work the same way? So we started thinking again about this idea of deep or the depth and the closeness of
那些跨文化连接的深度和亲密程度，可能会带来不同的影响。他们设计了一个实验来检验这一发现是否真实。这一次，他们只联系了那些既与不同国家的人约过会、又与自己同文化背景的人约过会的学生。随后，学生们被随机分成两组。在一种情况下，我们要求他们回忆自己与同文化背景的人约会的经历，并简单描述那种体验。而在另一种情况下，我们说：
those intercultural connections might make a difference. The designed an experiment to test whether the finding was real. This time they reached out only to students who had both dated someone from a different country and dated someone from their own country. The students were then randomly split into two groups. In one condition, we'll ask them to recall their experience they had with their dating someone from their own culture, and just describe that experience. Now, in the other condition, we said,
“回忆一次你与某个来自不同文化背景的人谈恋爱或建立关系的经历。那种体验是怎样的？”随后，研究人员让学生们反思他们对自身及另一种文化了解了多少。接着，他们接受了一项创造力测试。如果跨文化浪漫关系与创造力之间没有联系，那么让学生们反思不同类型的交往应该不会产生任何差异。但研究人员得到的结果并非如此。我们发现，仅仅通过反思跨文化关系，就会对暂时的创造力产生促进作用，而这 realmente 主要是因为人们觉得自己了解到了
we'll call a time when you dated about one of your relationships with someone from another culture. What was that experience like? Afterwards, the researchers asked the students to reflect on how much they learned about their own and the other culture. And then, they were given a test for creativity. If there was no connection between intercultural romance and creativity, asking the students to reflect on different kinds of encounters should have made no difference. But that's not what the researchers found. We found that there was a boost in temporary creativity just by reflecting on the intercultural relationship, and that was really driven by the fact that people felt that they had learned
更多关于另一种文化的知识，正是这种文化学习、这种反思以及这种文化学习带来了创造力的提升。塔夫茨大学的心理学研究也得出了类似的结果。当你向一个群体引入种族多样性时，群体中的所有人都会开始拓宽他们的思维视野，去探索更多的可能性。现在，创造力可能很难衡量，但科学家们已经设计出了衡量的方法。通常情况下，他们会分析所谓的发散思维和收敛思维。而收敛性创造力任务则是指那些只有一个正确答案的任务。
more about another culture, and that sort of cultural learning that reflection and that culture learning led to increased creativity. Psychology research out of Tufts University has found something similar. When you introduce racial diversity into a group, all the people in the group begin to broaden the scope of their thinking and to explore more options. Now, creativity can be difficult to measure, but scientists have devised ways of doing it. Typically, they analyze what they call, divergent thinking and convergent thinking. And convergent creativity tasks or ones in which there's a single right answer.
单有一个正确答案的最著名例子之一——虽然我们在这次特定的项目中没有真正使用它，但在我的许多其他研究中都用过——就是邓克蜡烛问题。在邓克蜡烛问题中，你要求人们，你给他们一支蜡烛、一盒图钉和一盒火柴。然后你告诉他们：把蜡烛固定在墙上，使得点燃蜡烛时，蜡油不会滴到墙壁、桌子或地板上。亚当说，当他在普林斯顿的一群聪明本科生中尝试这个测试时，只有极少数学生在15分钟内解出了这个问题。原因在于，这个测试要求你以一种全新的方式去思考熟悉的事物。
And one of the most famous examples of a single right answer that we didn't actually use in this particular project, but I've used them many of our other studies, is the Dunker Candle problem. And the Dunker Candle problem, you ask people to, you give them a candle, a box of tax, and a book of matches. And you tell them, fix the candle to a wall in such way that the candle when lit doesn't rip wax onto the wall, table, or floor. Adam says that when he tried this with a group of smart undergrads at Princeton, only a small percentage of the students solved the problem within 15 minutes. The reason is that the test requires you to think about familiar objects in a new way.
一盒图钉可以用来装图钉，但也可以成为一个支架。解决的办法是：你把盒子里的图钉全部倒出来，把盒子用图钉固定在墙上，然后把蜡烛放进盒子里。发散性任务则不要求唯一的正确答案。它们要求你产生大量不同的点子。在我们的研究中，我们在时间点一（即我们首次测量他们的创造力时）要求人们尽可能多地为一块砖头想出富有创造力的用途。然后到了时间点二（即他们从商学院毕业时），我们要求他们为纸箱想出尽可能多的创意用途。接着，你可以根据他们想出的用途数量对这些答案进行编码。但你也可以根据他们想出的不同类别数量进行编码。比如对于砖头，有人可能会说：“哦，它可以用来当家具的部件。”这是一个类别。或者它可以被用作武器，你可以把它扔向某人。这是另一个类别。或者它
A box of tax can be repository for tax, but can also be a stand. And the solution is you dump out all the tax out of the box, you tack the box to the wall, and then you put the candle inside. Divergent tasks don't ask for a single right answer. They require you to produce lots of different ideas. In our study, we ask people at time one, when we first measure their creativity, to generate as many creative uses as they can for brick. And then at time two, when they graduated from business school, we asked them to think about as many creative uses they could for a box. And then you can code these uses for the number of uses they come up with. But you can also code them for the number of different categories they come up with. So for a brick, someone might say, oh, it could be used as a piece of furniture. So that's one category. Or it could be used as the weapon. You could throw it at someone. That's another category. Or it could
可以被用作家居的一部分，这是又一个类别。同样，产生大量好的点子是充满创造力的大脑的标志。在针对商学院学生的这项研究中，亚当和他的同事们给了志愿者们最后一项任务。这被称为“远程联想测验”。测试中，你给人们三个词，然后要求他们找出能将这三个词连接起来的那个词。人们给出的一个经典例子是：给你这三个词——man、round和tennis。你必须想出一个
be used as part of a house, that's another category. Again, generating lots of good ideas is a sign of a creative brain. In the study of business school students, Adam and his colleagues gave the volunteers one final task. It's called the Remote Associates Test. Where you get people three words, and then you ask them basically to find the one word that connects them. And one of the classic examples that people give is you're given these three words, manner, round, and tense. And you've got to come up with the one
能把这三者全部联系起来的词。在这个例子中，答案是table（桌子）。为什么？你可以有table manners（餐桌礼仪），你可以有round tables（圆桌），你还可以有table tennis（乒乓球）。亚当和他的同事们发现，在每一个这样的测试中，被随机选出来反思自己与异国恋经历的志愿者群体，其表现都优于那些被要求反思与本国人恋爱经历的群体。他们的思维灵活性以及想法的新颖性都有所提升，基本上在我们的最终数据中，我们构建了一个单一的综合创造力得分，它实际上
word that connects all three of them. And in this case, the answer is table. Why? You can have table manners, you can have round tables, and you can have table tennis. What Adam and his colleagues found is that in every one of these tests, the group of volunteers randomly selected to reflect on their experience dating someone from another country, outperformed those asked to reflect on their experience, dating someone from their own country. They increased in their flexibility and novelty of their ideas and basically in our final data what we did is we basically created a single composite creativity score which really
融合了所有这些测试，但在每一个单独的问题上也出现了相同的效应，这表明该效应是多么稳健和强大。这些发现引人入胜。研究人员决定更进一步。他们想知道这些结果在现实世界中是否依然成立。正当他们苦思冥想如何做到这一点时，有一天，亚当去听了同事丹·王的一个演讲。丹展示了一个非常惊人的数据集，记录了所有持J1签证访问美国的人，并对他们进行了调查。J1签证允许人们在限定时间内在美国工作，通常在三个月到两年之间。在任何给定的时间，大约有30万名J1签证持有人。
collapsed across all these but the same effect actually emerges on each of the individual problems which shows how robust and powerful the effect was. The findings were intriguing. The researchers decided to go a step further. They wanted to know if the results would hold up in the real world. They were wondering how to do that when one day Adam went to a presentation given by his colleague Dan Wong. And here's presenting this great amazing data set of everyone who had a J1 visa to visit the US and he was able to survey them. J1 visas allow people to work in the United States for a defined period of time, usually between three months and two years. At any given time, there are about 300,000 J1 visa holders.
这意味着我们有大量的人来到美国相对较短的一段时间——最长可达24个月，也就是差不多两年——然后返回他们的祖国。演讲结束后，亚当走到丹面前，问他是否偶然拥有任何关于跨文化接触及其连接深度的客观数据。他说：“我想我有的。”事实证明，丹曾向这些前J1签证持有人提出过这样一个问题：请汇报你返回祖国后与美国朋友保持联系的频率。
So that means that we have tons of people who have come to the US for a relatively short period time, but you know up to 24 months, almost two years, and then return back to their home country. After the talk, Adam went up to Dad and asked him, if by any chance, he had any data on cross-cultural contact and the depth of those connections. He said, I think I do. It turned out, Dan had us former J1 visa holders this question. Please report the frequency of contact that you have with your American friends since you have returned to your home country.
该调查还询问了这些前签证持有人自回国以来一直在从事什么样的工作。亚当开始查看这些数据，看看那些与美国朋友保持最密切联系的人，与他们回国后是否成为企业家并创立了自己的公司之间，是否存在某种相关性；以及他们在回国后是否在自己的公司里创造了新的实践。确实存在。他说：“哦，天哪，数据正如你所预测的那样。”所以这真的是这篇论文的锦上添花之笔。
The survey also asked the former visa holders what kind of work they'd been doing since returning home. Adam has done to take a look at his data and see if there was a correlation between those who'd maintained the closest contact with their American friends and whether they became an entrepreneur when they got home and founded their own company and whether they had created new practices in their company when they got home. Indeed there was. He said, oh my god, the data are exactly as you would have predicted. And so that was really the icing on the cake of this paper.
你知道的，我们已经有了来自实验室的、基于纸笔的创造力测量优秀数据，但现在我们有了假说的核心支撑，即跨文化关系的深度、他们保持联系的频率，能够预测这些现实世界中具有重大影响的创造力指标——即他们成为企业家并创办自己公司的概率，以及他们在自己的公司中做出改变、转型和创新的程度。这一次，亚当和他的同事们没有被人抢先。他们的论文成功发表了。亚当说，他看到创造力与文化多样性之间的联系越来越多。当然会有了。
You know, we'd already had this great data from laboratory-based paper and pencil creativity measures, but now we have the core of our hypothesis, that the depth of intercultural relationships, the frequency which they had contact predicts these real world, consequential creativity measures, the probability that they became an entrepreneur and started their own business and how much they changed and transformed and innovated in their own companies. This time, Adam and his colleagues did not get scooped. They got published. Adam says he sees more and more links between creativity and cultural diversity. You bet I'll work.
在他最喜欢的项目之一中，他研究了各大时装屋在21个季度里推出的时装系列。米兰、巴黎、伦敦和纽约。他发现，创造力与服装设计师在不同文化中沉浸的时间之间似乎存在着某种联系。而我们发现了一个非常有趣的现象，那就是创意总监在国外工作的时间长短预示着他们整个时装系列的创造力，但他们在国外工作过的国家数量则不然。后者产生的影响远不及他们在国外工作的时间长短。
In one of his favorite projects, he looked at fashion lines presented by major fashion houses over 21 seasons. Milan, Paris, London and New York. He found that there appeared to be a connection between creativity and the time that fashion creators had spent immersed in a different culture. And what we found was something really interesting, which is that the amount of time that the creative director had worked abroad predicted their entire fashion line creativity, but not the number of countries that they worked abroad. That didn't have near as much of an impact as the amount of time that they worked abroad.
所有这些例子都有一个共同的线索。时装设计师们看起来很像商学院里与异国恋人交往的学生。这些学生看起来很像花时间与不同种族合作伙伴合作的科学家。那些与不同传统的表演者合作的音乐家，与那些建立广泛联系并花时间维护它们的创业者有着共同点。所有这些跨文化关系所共同具备的是：深度。这里面有一种东西，那就是深入理解
All these examples have a common thread. The fashion designers look a lot like the students at business school who dated someone from another country. The students look a lot like the scientists who spend time collaborating with partners from different ethnicities. The musicians who work with someone from a different tradition have something in common with the entrepreneurs who make broad connections and spend time maintaining them. What all these cross cultural relationships have is depth. There's something about deeply understanding
并学习另一种文化，具有变革性的力量。我们可以通过在海外生活来获得这种体验。我们可以通过与不同文化背景的人约会来获得这种体验。我们甚至可以通过旅行来获得，但前提是我们真正去了解、理解、拥抱并适应了在海外旅行时遇到的那种异质文化。所以我想，那个非常稳健的重大科学结论是：
and learning about another culture that's transformative. We can get that from living abroad. We can get that from dating someone from another culture. We could even get it from traveling, but only if we really learned and understood and embraced and adapted to that other culture why we were traveling abroad. And so I think the big scientific conclusion
真正、真正、深深地理解另一种文化，才是提升你自身创造力的关键。亚当·吉林斯基和他的妻子珍表示，他们希望自己的孩子能以这种广阔的视角看待世界。正如亚当所说，他的研究之美在于，它表明广泛合作的好处其实触手可及，尤其是在美国。你不一定要出国，就能获得这种跨文化接触带来的创造力益处。你完全可以在美国本土，通过拥抱并参与到与其他文化的交往中，获得同样的益处。但话说回来，这里也有一个前提。这种交往不能仅仅浮于表面。
that is very robust is that it's about really, truly, deeply understanding another culture is the key to enhancing your own creativity. Adam Galinsky and his wife, Jen, say they want their children to see the world in this expansive way. At Adam says, the beauty of his research is that it suggests the benefits of broad collaboration are within easy reach, especially in the United States. You don't have to go abroad to get some of the creativity benefits of having that intercultural contact. You can get that same benefit here in the United States by embracing engaging with people from other cultures. But again, there's the catch. It can't just be superficial.
你必须与来自其他文化的人进行更深层次的连接，才能产生那种变革性的影响和体验。你可能会认为，我们今天讨论的一些例子存在局限性。那些与多元团队合作的科学家，或是与来自其他传统的表演者组队的音乐家，这些人可能本身就是乐于冒险的人。换句话说，并不是音乐合作让你变得更具创造力，而仅仅是因为你拥有开放的心态。
You've got to more deeply connect the people from other cultures to have that transformational impact in that experience. You could argue there are limitations in some of the examples we've discussed today. It's possible that scientists who collaborate with diverse teams or musicians who team up with performers from other traditions, these people might just be risk-takers. In other words, it's not the musical collaborations that make you more creative, it's just having an open outlook.
要以科学的方式探讨这类问题是非常困难的。我们无法进行这样的实验：由我们来决定谁和谁约会，或者科学家应该和谁合作。但我认为，即便在无法证明因果关系的的研究中，你依然可以看到多元化对创造力产生的影响。这不仅体现在个人层面，还体现在社群层面，甚至国家层面。试想一下：美国，这个仅占世界人口约5%的国家，
It's very difficult to explore questions like this scientifically. We can't conduct experiments where we dictate who people date or who scientists should collaborate with. But I would argue that even in studies where you can't prove cause and effect, you can still see the effects that diversity has on creativity. And this is not just at the level of individuals, it's at the level of communities, even nations. Consider this. The United States, a country that accounts for about 5% of the world's population,
却获得了所有已颁发诺贝尔奖中大约60%的奖项。从汽车、飞机到Facebook和谷歌，从电话、互联网到好莱坞和华尔街，来自美国的科学家、企业家和演艺人员深刻地塑造了我们今天生活的世界。这种超常规的创造力，是否与美国非凡的多元化、几个世纪以来涌入这里的海量移民有关呢？我倾向于认为答案是肯定的。
has won about 60% of all the Nobel Prizes ever awarded. From the motor car and the airplane to Facebook and Google, from the telephone and the internet to Hollywood and Wall Street, scientists, entrepreneurs and entertainers from the United States have powerfully shaped the world in which we live. Could some of this outside's creativity have to do with the extraordinary diversity of America, the waves of immigrants who arrived here over the centuries? I'd like to think the answer is yes.
赢得了大约60%的诺贝尔奖。从汽车、飞机到Facebook和Google，从电话、互联网到好莱坞和华尔街，来自美国的科学家、企业家和演艺人员有力地塑造了我们生活的世界。这种外来创造力的一部分是否与美国非凡的多样性有关，与几个世纪以来来到这里的移民潮有关？我愿意相信答案是肯定的。
Today's episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell, and Kat Shuknik. The song you're listening to right now is Volio. It's composed by Christina Pado and Kogira Umazaki. It blends the Japanese Sakohachi with the Galithian Batpipe. Thanks to the team at WNYC's Soundcheck for sharing this recording with us.
今天的节目由珍妮·施密特和帕斯·沙阿制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡特·舒克尼克。你现在听到的这首歌是《Volio》。它由克里斯蒂娜·帕多和小栗马崎作曲。它将日本尺八与加利西亚风笛融合在一起。感谢WNYC节目《Soundcheck》的团队与我们分享这段录音。
This week, our unsung hero is Lynette Clemetson. Lynette is currently director of the Night Wallace Fellowships program for journalists, but before that, she was a beloved colleague here at NPR. She believes, with every bone in her body, in the link between diversity and creativity. Lynette was an early and ardent supporter of Hidden Brain, where literally would not exist without her. In fact, I can't believe we haven't previously called her out as an unsung hero. Of course, that is precisely what makes her an unsung hero. If you like today's show, please share it with one friend who comes from a different
本周，我们的无名英雄是莱内特·克莱门特森。莱内特目前担任奈特·华莱士记者奖学金项目的总监，但在那之前，她是NPR备受爱戴的同事。她坚信多元化与创造力之间存在密不可分的联系。莱内特是《隐形大脑》早期坚定的支持者，如果没有她，这个节目简直无法存在。事实上，我简直不敢相信我们以前没有公开称赞她为无名英雄。当然，这正是她成为无名英雄的原因。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给一位来自不同背景的朋友
cultural background, tell us about your conversation on Facebook and Twitter. I'm Shankar Vidantan and this is NPR. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go.
文化背景的朋友，在Facebook和Twitter上告诉我们你们的对话。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。
I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. I'm going to have to go. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。我得走了。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。